it's been uh the me too movement has
happened since the last time i was here
well no it had to happen jesus christ
but you know i think it's dying down
you know i don't know i think they got
everybody
all right
yeah so the stories were big in the
beginning like oh my god what a bunch of
[ __ ] animals
and then they just started tapering
tapering off
and about i don't know six months in
they just sounded like bad dates
it was like he was he was 10 minutes
late
the chicken was cold i think i was raped
career
over what about my side of the story
[ __ ] your side of the story you have
dick and balls we don't want to hear it
the craziest thing about that is did you
guys read the aziz story
yo this [ __ ] is wild
this is a wild boy right here bro this
dude got his dick
sucked to seinfeld
you know how much you gotta love comedy
to get your dick sucked to seinfeld
that's pure dialogue yo i can't get my
dick sucked
these pretzels are making me thirsty
new men i can't get my dick sucked into
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that i get my dick sucked
to fast and they're furious
that [ __ ] is built in birth control you
ever [ __ ] the fast and furious
you getting in there raw and then all of
a sudden you hear vin diesel like family
you're like oh [ __ ] let me tell you
all right you're right ben hey you're
right ben
i appreciate you dog make another one of
them [ __ ]
let's talk about serious things then the
me too campaign
yes what what's wrong with the industry
i mean are you asking yourself how how
come all of this is the industry honey
it's the whole
gender it's men and women this is about
men and women
you just call me honey yeah because you
got to get with this it's not
show business this is global did you see
any of it
because everyone's saying it was all
around and everyone knew about it but
then
well which who are we talking about just
things that were going on
around in studios honestly i've never
seen
and uh during the years when i worked on
my show
and even in the night clubs i mean a lot
of
the comedians uh there was a lot of
activity let's call it frivolity
uh comedians and waitresses and
everybody i mean men and women you know
chase after each other
right right yes
yes they do now i've never seen it done
in a way that was uh
that i thought that's not right so
what's that guys doing so you're
surprised with all this me too
uh campaign and things that are coming
out now no i'm not surprised but you
asked me if i'd seen it
so i i i haven't one of them is also
actually
um your friend or someone you worked
with louis ck
that's terrible i mean these behaviors
themselves don't even make sense
sexually it's like
i don't even understand why they would
do that and is it something that would
cause you not to listen to him anymore
not to be
i mean not to listen to his material
think it's right that they took him
he stopped he stopped working the
problem for him will be
no one will ever ever look at him
without thinking about that
and he knows that i don't understand the
uh
um the syndrome harvey the showering
what fun is it to shower for somebody i
don't even understand it
who wants to watch anybody's shower
where's the excitement of that
only if it's on a movie set yeah it's a
whole world of sexuality that's kind of
caught people by surprise it's like
you're doing what
this is a horrible story it's not even a
good story this is like where it's hard
to be a man
one lady said louis ck masturbating in
front of me
ruined my comedy dreams word
well then i dare say madam you may have
never had a dream
come on man that's a brittle spirit i i
just looked at it this way it's like
this [ __ ] was like a [ __ ] pressure
cooker because no one was listening so
in a way
it's it's deserving on the male side
that this is happening but it's [ __ ]
exploding now
but any sort of like hey hey okay okay
let's let's let's find out what happened
yeah
well you know there's there's none
there's none of that i've actually heard
the argument
that we shouldn't break down and explain
the degrees and the differences of these
accusations
like i've heard well i think that's
because there needs to be a corrective
first right there needs to be a
correction the pendulum like bill said
was so far on this end and everybody's
so [ __ ] angry so now the pendulum is
way here and now with the last thing
with the aziz story
i think people are starting to go well
wait a minute maybe there's gray areas
to this discussion it's not just
there's gray areas to everything
everything if you work if you look at
people who created law who are way
smarter than me
yeah you know what i mean there's
there's there's misdemeanors and there's
there's
felonies yeah it's murder one there's
murder to this manslaughter people that
are
in this thing with with their anger
especially if they're emotional about it
don't even want to entertain that
conversation
they are just like it's it's like you
you're trying to sell somebody like
hey armed robbery and shoplifting are
different right and they're saying no
somebody took something that's the same
yeah take their be had them in the
i think you're being unreasonable
because you're so emotional which is a
totally fair thing to say
but everybody else who's kind of
thinking logically
i think is open to the idea that no the
majority of the majority of the people
are
any time i've said that on stage yeah
like there's no like oh my god
heckling's shouting down there's no like
[ __ ] problems uh same thing when you
talk about the war
there hasn't really been any problem but
everybody is afraid to like
you know it's it's not good to um
you know when it's it's this level of
emotional reaction yeah
to to just just lay back and just be
like just okay
just don't get involved don't get
involved because it's gonna
it you know god i mean you know the
thing about
a sex thing is if you if you just get
accused of it i've said for the longest
time like
if you get accused of rape they
shouldn't show your face or name until
you're convicted
right because once somebody just gets
accuses you of it you're
[ __ ] you're fine and done not to
mention even if you were just accused of
it like
everybody in your own like personal life
you work that's gonna get out
of course and now social media
everyone's going to rat you out anyways
and it's just like
there's there's no come back from that
and if you're actually innocent
and i've seen people going like well the
instances of that are really rare it's
like
look them up yeah there's enough of them
that there should be
some sort of thing like that but i just
don't think you can keep anything under
a lid anymore
but um i really do believe that it's a
time for
like you know uh to not be afraid
um when you're on stage especially as a
comedian like all like they're just
starting to like
you know uh paint this is the weirdest
thing like when i was
i was on stage i was joking well there
was like this younger crowd
and usually when you get to my age you
start getting 50 it's like you kind of
become like the cornball like hey take
my wife please you know like your style
becomes old
but they are so under a microscope they
act like old people so
like i i was watching i was at a show
last night there was a couple guys like
my age we're like the edgy guys
right they should be the corn balls
right looking at the 20 something year
olds
in the crowd being like jesus christ
these people are going to be running the
nation
oh my god remember back in our day we
just did dick jokes what are these
i'm not really saying the comedians i'm
just saying the way the crowd yes
it's like you're on [ __ ] doing a
bunch of old people on a cruise ship
[Music]
we took a lot of flack for for saying uh
in the art of for some things that you
said
in the hollywood reporter saying that
you were kind of glad that the
metoo movement has slowed down and we
don't really know you as a guy who you
know really comments on
very much that's going on so were you
trying what were you trying to say
yeah well i was you know print reporters
they asked you questions and then put
them all together what i was talking
about was
that chris hardwick this particular
comedian right that was a friend of mine
and uh you know if 500
women go against a man obviously the
guy's guilty
but then chris hardwick won it was one
woman against one man
that's fine you know so i was saying
that i thought it was good that the
pendulum was slowing and chris hardwick
has been as rehabilitated as he's going
to get he's still tells me he can't walk
down the street without people
yelling stuff at him yeah but uh that's
so that's all i was trying to do okay
this is a movement that was you know
largely uh shouldered by a kind of
receptacle of the salacious do you mean
a receptacle of the salacious well we
don't know what's a fact
in many of the cases salacious is as
soon as you
s you call something a movement that is
really a series of many individual
accusers victims accusations
many some of which are unfounded the
spirit of much of what has been the
metoo movement is to divide
men and women the women would say it's
united women i'm going to say that women
that i talk to
not in front of a camera that i listen
to
all of all walks of life
that there is a common sense that is not
represented at all in the discussion
when it comes to the media discussion of
it
the the discussion where if sean penn
says this
so and so is going to attack him for
saying this because of that
i don't want it to be a trend and i'm
very suspicious
of a movement that gets glommed onto in
great
in great stridency and rage and without
nuance
and even when people try to discuss it
in a nuanced way
the nuance itself is attacked have you
guys ever lived the life of a comedian
have you lived the life of a [ __ ]
rock or have you lived the life
of a perfect a person in the public eye
it's got his perks and it's got its
negatives okay
one of the perks is for some reason
women lose their [ __ ] mind over
certain things when
when the movie motley crew came out the
crew whatever on netflix
it opens up with him eating the girl's
[ __ ] that was a squirter at a party and
it was
you know that was motley crue they came
over the [ __ ]
you know right and rudy sarzo said to
megan what'd you think of the movie
because i enjoyed it
it was entertaining he goes it's just
really hard to
understand all the me too
how come people are freaking out more
about me too because that was a
different time
that was the 80s it was a different
[ __ ] time
you know i'm not saying it was okay to
rape women or put sleeping pills and i
don't know
anything about that but what went on the
road
was just you know it was man i've sat
here with you
many at night one night especially up
the top of the corner here
when i was still living up the corner
and we talked i was shaking
i'm telling you of all the [ __ ] crazy
encounters you have
as a young comic on the road and how
crazy they really are you know
and you can look at it from two ways you
look at it from any way you want
i mean it's just it's a weird way of
living
you know and now we're seeing it through
the years with harvey and
[ __ ] cosby now people's eyes are
getting a little bit
more woken to what happens out here and
you you know so you get mad at a guy
like cosby
and harvey but there's another side to
the story and that's the side of
meeting a celebrity or sleeping with a
celebrity or
getting help from that celebrity okay
um and let me tell you something
i i always knew
for some reason i got an early idea
early on
that nobody could help you in this
business
i kind of figured out that the people i
liked
all stood on that stage alone and that
really nobody can help you i mean it's
the craziest thing that you think that
somebody could shine light on you yes
somebody could say diana ross could walk
into a room and say hmm
i like the jackson five but the jackson
fives still have to do their work
you know i'm saying and once you realize
that
but for some reason a lot of women come
out here
they're a little on the hot side you
know they know it
there you go a little garlic fartfully i
told them one was coming
you spread that [ __ ] all the time right
now wait for this this will kill corona
corona's cousin
and every [ __ ] buck i think that's
where corona got started
just forget the bad move on this will
kill everybody